today i have kristen
cenani kristen saynani is an associate
professor at the stanford university
she teaches statistics in writing works
on statistical projects in sports
medicine
and writes about health science and
statistics for a range of audiences
she authored the health column body news
for allure magazine for a decade
she is also the statistical editor for
the journal physical medicine and
rehabilitation
and she authors a statistics column
statistically speaking for this journal
she teaches the popular massive open
online course
writing in the sciences on coursera she
was a recipient of the 2018
biosciences award for excellence in
graduate teaching
at stanford university so thank you all
for being here and i will now pass it
over to kristen for our presentation
today
thanks jackie so yeah today i'm going to
be
talking about how to analyze research
data
and my goal for today is to allow you to
peer under the hood
of a real data analysis unfortunately i
think
many phd students and applied
researchers are never taught the data
analysis pipeline
they may be taught just you know a tiny
sliver of data analysis
such as you know how to run specific
statistical tests
but there's so much more to data
analysis and so today i'm going to walk
you through all of the steps and
including my
thought process in those steps
and i'm going to use a real example
these are data that i am actually
currently analyzing since these are
unpublished data i'm just going to share
a subset of the data today so as not to
give away the whole story but i'll tell
you
that what i am seeing in the subset is
pretty similar to what i'm seeing in the
larger data set i want to thank the pi
of the study dr emily krause for
allowing me to use her data in teaching
so this study is a cross-sectional
survey that was administered online
and today we're going to look at data on
409 competitive adult female runners
and the study was interested in a
syndrome called female athlete triad
so this is where athletes don't intake
enough calories
for the amount that they are expending
in exercise
that can lead to energy deficiency which
can in turn
cause women to lose their menstrual
periods and have lowered levels of
estrogen
which in turn can cause them to lose
bone and have fragile bones
so the research question for this study
was do runners with female athlete triad
have an increased prevalence of
depression or anxiety
the main independent variable for this
study was something called the female
athlete triad risk
score so this is a validated risk score
that's actually used to screen athletes
for female athlete triad
and you get points for low energy
availability
which is related to like restrictive
eating behaviors
for low bmi for irregular periods
for late menarche which is a delayed
first period
and for having a history of bone stress
injuries
the dependent variables are depression
and anxiety and these were measured by a
validated questionnaire
called the promise questionnaire which
is actually frequently used in
research all right so now let's talk
about the steps of a data analysis i've
broken it down today into five main
steps
so you're first going to process and
clean your data to get it ready for
analysis
then you need to spend time
familiarizing yourself with all of the
variables in your data set
this is going to help inform step three
which is when you actually get to test
the main hypotheses of your study
then you need to check for robustness so
what this means is
you're going to make small tweaks to the
analysis and make sure that the whole
thing doesn't fall apart if it falls
apart then it's not robust
and finally you have to get everything
ready for publication
which includes coming up with a story in
your
a set of tables and figures that tell
the story of your data and spend some
time really thinking about
how to put those together so it's a
clear story
and you have to prepare final code
documents
when i do a data analysis i actually
spend the majority of my
time in steps one and two
and uh they're they're time-consuming
and i would also argue that these are
the
most important steps of any good data
analysis
and this is because if there are quirks
in your data that you are not aware of
or if there are errors in your data it
doesn't matter how good your statistical
model is
it's a garbage in garbage situation then
and i actually think that a lot of the
errors that i see in the published
literature
arise because researchers often
neglect steps one and two everybody
wants to rush to step three to testing
those main hypotheses
but if you don't do due diligence on
your data that really is a big source of
burst
um again unfortunately i think everybody
wants to you know rush to step three
and most statistical tests there were
many statistical courses
actually focus almost exclusively on you
know
step three there on how to do specific
statistical tests
like how to run a t-test or how to run
an anova
and that may give researchers the
mistaken impression that
data analysis is synonymous with step
three up there
when in fact step three is just a tiny
sliver of a
done data analysis as we're going to see
today
so what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to walk you through the steps of
a data analysis using this example of
female athlete triad and mental health
so first thing we're going to do is
process and clean our data
and there's just a lot of things
involved in this step
it does take quite a bit of time and you
might think
oh this step is going to be really
tedious uh but actually
i actually really enjoy cleaning data
so um there's something fun uh there's
something that's a little bit of like
numerical detective work
when you're digging into your data and
trying to find like all the things that
could have gone wrong so i find that
fun and then there's just something
really satisfying about cleaning your
data i mean i
think it's kind of like when you go into
the back of that closet
that you haven't cleaned for like 10
years and you pull everything out and
you kind of wash down the shelves
and throw things out and organize
everything there's just something really
nice about knowing at the back of the
closet even though you can't see it
that it's in order and i feel the same
way about just knowing that my data are
important
so the first thing you're going to do in
this step is you're usually getting data
in from somewhere like qualtrics or a
red cap
what you're going to do is you're going
to immediately import those data
into a proper statistical analysis
program something like
r or sas where you can write code to do
your data processing and
also your analysis eventually and
i want to make the point that you really
shouldn't be processing data
in excel and the reason i bring this up
is that i realized over the years that
there's a lot of researchers who are
very
comfortable in excel and so they're
tempted to do a lot of their data
processing
in itself this is just a bad idea
because it's highly inefficient um
i'll give you an example i got brought
in on a project a few
years ago and when the data were entered
in red cap there had been some
issue where i think some of the baseline
data points had been entered in a
follow-up column
and so there was a there was an error
the pi of that study had
downloaded the data into excel and was
going through
observation by observation to realign
everything
which probably took her 30 or 40 hours
of work
i was able to download the data from red
cap and
dump it into sas and write like four
lines of code
and fix the problem in 20 minutes so if
you're processing data in excel you're
probably wasting time
if you could write some code to do the
same thing it's going to be much more
efficient
i also don't like excel for processing
data because when you're working in cell
itself there's a high chance of
accidentally introducing errors
and there's no real record of them and
it's not reproducible
the other thing is when you update your
data say in redcap
if you've done everything in excel
you're going to have to download and
you're going to have to repeat all of
those manual steps in excel
whereas if you've written code you just
port your data your new data back into
sas or r and you rewrite your code it
takes two seconds to update
so other things we're going to be doing
here is i spent a lot of time renaming
variables so they come in
from qualtrics or redcap with funny
names and i'm not going to remember
those names so i'm going to name them
something i can remember and type easily
i'm also going to be calculating new
values so in this example data set
the participants took a questionnaire
about depression and it was eight
questions long
those eight questions get processed into
a single depression score so i'm going
to write some
code to do that i'm also going to spend
a lot of time
rummaging around in my data checking for
errors and this is time consuming
and i actually spent a lot of time
actually emailing back and forth with
the pi
and the people who are maintaining the
database to see if we can resolve those
errors
or sometimes they're not errors they're
just weird data points and we have to
decide how to score those
we're also going to worry about how to
handle missing data and i'm going to
figure out you know if any observations
need to be excluded
all right just for fun what i'm showing
you here is
the data processing and cleaning code
that i have written for this particular
data analysis
this is sas code i do most of my data
processing in sas actually
but you can see it's 12 pages long so
this is a lot of work
data processing and cleaning in contrast
i'm going to show you a regression model
later that regression model took like
five lines of code
so a lot of work goes into data
processing and cleaning
so as i mentioned we're gonna get data
often for research data is gonna be
something like from qualtrics um
the data for this study were entered
into qualtrics
so what i'm showing you in this screen
now is what the spreadsheet looks like
when i download
the data from qualtrics and i'm just
showing you the variables for height
and weight so height was entered
actually in two separate columns
they asked the participants to report
their height as feet
and then separately as the remaining
inches and then weight was just asked in
one column
as weight in pounds notice that the
variable names here
are really awful like q93 underscore 39
underscore text i'm
never going to remember that so i'm
going to rename that variable into
something easy like
height i'm going to write some code
that's going to clean this data up i'm
going to rename
the height variable to height i'm going
to combine those two columns into a
single column
so if you entered 5 feet 7 inches i'm
just going to calculate that your 67
inches tall
weight i'm going to rename that variable
and then i calculated
bmi from their height and weight
the height data actually makes a really
good example to talk about
checking the need for checking your data
for errors
so that variable was asking in sort of a
weird way they were asked to answer
uh how many feet are you and then how
many inches are you so like you were
supposed to put in
five feet four inches but there were a
lot of variations on how that got
entered
when i went to calculate height what i
did was to take their feet variable
multiply by 12 and add inches to get the
height in
inches but that led to some impossible
and weird height values which i then
fished out of the data set to try to
resolve what was going on
so for example some people came out with
heights of like 124 and 125 inches
well why did that happen so actually
it turned out i could figure out some of
what went on here
so some people when they were asked to
answer feet they put you know five feet
but then when they were asked for the
inches they didn't put the remaining
inches like four inches
they put their height in total engines
like i'm 64 inches tall
well obviously when i went to calculate
height i came up with this weird value
but this one is resolvable i know what
they meant they meant that they're 64
inches tall so i can
easily fix that that is not a problem
i'll just change that to 64 or 65 inches
another thing people did is when they
were asked the height
they put in uh for the feet a decimal
place like
five i'm 5.44 feet tall and then they
didn't enter anything for inches
so when i went to calculate height i got
a missing value
but this one is also resolvable right i
know what they meant i'm just going to
take the 5.44 and multiply by 12
and i am able to fill in for example
that 5.44 feet
corresponds to 65 inches no problem
now there were some heights that in the
end i couldn't resolve they just have
weird values so you know somebody
entered eight feet eight
inches maybe they meant five feet eight
inches but i can't really tell
um somebody entered two feet four inches
i don't know what that means
so these heights actually can't be
calculated um which means i'm not going
to be able to get a bmi for this person
so i'm just gonna leave those data as
missing and these people will be missing
a bmi just fun little story though
uh the magic of crowdsourcing on twitter
here
uh last week i posted on twitter about
this upcoming webinar and i showed this
particular slide
and an observant researcher out there
kat daniels
uh tweeted back and said hey that one
that says one foot 85 inches
maybe they used metric units i hadn't
thought of that and but it totally makes
sense right one meter
85 centimeters that translates to about
72 or 73 inches
so we may have resolved that one data
point just through the magic of twitter
all right another thing we had to do
with these data
is the participants took this promise
depression
questionnaire and this consists of eight
questions about depression and they're
things like in the past seven days
how often have you been bothered by the
following symptoms and it's things like
i felt worthless or i felt sad
the participants answered this question
on a likert scale
rarely never sometimes often
uh and those answers get
translated all eight answers on those
eight questions get
translated into a single depression
score
that ranges from eight to forty so i
wrote some code to process those data
and i named the new variable def now for
like current depression
and we end up with a score between 8 and
40.
now for this particular variable i did
have to think carefully about
missing data so you'll notice that some
people didn't fill out any of the
questions
these are actually pretty easy cases
because they're just going to get a
missing value for
depression in fact what happened on this
because it was
an online survey is that some people
signed up to take the survey
they got like you know two or three
questions in and then they abandoned the
whole thing they decided maybe it wasn't
worth their time
so we have a bunch of people who
basically have blanks on everything
obviously they're going to be excluded
from the analysis in the end so those
cases are in some ways easy
but then i have cases like the one that
you see up here now
where uh this person answered seven of
the eight questions
but they neglected to answer question
six so what do i do with this person
do i give them a depression score or do
i treat their depression score as
missing
i just think carefully carefully about
what to do here
and so to figure that out what i did was
to do a little bit more detective work
is i went into the data set and tried to
quantify how often
were people missing items on the
depression
questionnaire and so i just counted up
how often were people missing zero items
meaning that they answered all the
questions
how often were they missing one item
they just missed one question
how often were they missing all eight
and fortunately
it turns out that most of the cases are
pretty easy
most people either answered all of the
questions
or they answered none of them so those
are easy cases
we only had five participants who had
partial data on the depression questions
so there were three people who actually
missed one item
there were there was one person who
missed three items and there was one
person who missed four items
so i had to make just a decision about
what to do about these people
and so it made sense to me to say hey if
you're missing one item
i can just give you the minimum score on
that one item
and i can still give you a depression
score that's going to be reasonably
accurate
but if you were missing three or four
items that seemed like i wasn't going to
be able to get an accurate depression
score
so i'm going to count those people as
having missing a missing value for
depression
so overall i ended up with 58
participants who didn't get a depression
score
and in this particular analysis there
were three main variables the triad risk
score
the depression score and the anxiety
score and if you were missing any one of
those you really couldn't contribute
much to the analysis since those are the
key variables
so when i we started here with 476
people who started the survey
but when i excluded people who were
missing any one of those three main
variables
we ended up with a final sample size of
all right so what are we going to do
next now we're going to get to step two
this is a step where you familiarize
yourself with all the variables in your
data set you really have to
dig in to make sure that you understand
all of the variables and really
understand what's going on in your data
this is really going to help inform step
three the the model building step
so what are we doing here well one thing
i love to do
is i love to make a bunch of histograms
with my data i just plot a histogram of
each individual variable
to look at the distribution and actually
uh fun story
i teach a three-quarter statistics
sequence
at stanford so i have many of the same
students all year
long and i've probably been giving
presenting a lot of histograms to them
all year long
so in the spring quarter we do these
data analysis projects
and so the other day they had just
gotten a new data set and they were
working together in teams
in breakout rooms on zoom and i was
floating around the breakout rooms
and my heart was warm so much because
immediately
all that uh you know a lot of my
students were immediately drawing
histograms of their data so it was their
instincts
to look at the distributions and
histograms so i felt like i taught them
something
i'm also going to be in this step
calculating descriptive statistics
i'm going to be really understanding
each variable and i'm going to be
exploring simple
relationships between the variables
which variables go together
so as an example here's the histogram
for age in my data set so what are we
looking at a histogram
on the x-axis we have different ranges
of age on the y-axis we have how
frequently
different ages occur so for example i
had
you know this is roughly about 18 to
just over 20 i had about 10 percent of
my sample in that you know 18 to 20
buckets
what turned out to be interesting here
is that i actually have a pretty wide
range of ages so i actually have some
women who are in their late
50s and i have some women who are
actually post-menopausal
and this turns out to be really
important i had to email back and forth
with the pi of the study to say hey
how do we score postmenopausal women for
menstrual irregularity which is one of
our key variables
just being aware that the age range is
so wide also reminds me that i'm going
to need to control for age in my
analyses
this next histogram that i'm showing you
shows the distribution of the triad risk
scores
remember this is my main independent
variable
so this risk score ranges from 0 to 10
and 10 means that you have more traits
of the female athlete triad
i'll just point out that we had only one
person who scored a nine and only one
person
scored a 10. so those really high scores
were actually rare
uh i'm going to say a little bit more
about where this score comes from now
so the triad risk score comes from
summing up
five individual components that are each
scored on a scale from zero to
two so for example
you get points for menstrual
irregularity
if you have normal periods your score is
zero if you have somewhat irregular
periods you get a score of one
and if you're missing periods altogether
you get a score of two
you also get points for late menarche a
late first period
so if you had a your first period at age
15 you get a score of one
if it's age 16 or older you get a score
of two
you get points for prior bone stress
injuries so if you've had one stress
reaction or stress fracture
you get one point if you've had more
than one you get two points
you get points for a low bmi so under
18.5 that's one point
under 17.5 that's two points
and then finally you get points for low
energy availability
and this is scored actually in this data
set based on a series of questions
that we asked the participants about
their eating behaviors and we were
really looking for restrictive eating
behaviors that might limit the amount of
calories
that somebody was taking in
i think this low energy availability
risk score actually turns out to be kind
of an
important part of the whole story here
so i'm going to say just
a little bit more about this risk score
so the participants were actually asked
a pretty long series of questions about
eating behaviors
including you know a history of eating
disorders had they ever been diagnosed
with an eating disorder
and they were asked if they engaged in
certain restrictive eating behaviors and
they were asked how frequently they
engaged in those behaviors and also
things like purging
if they had a history of eating
disorders or a frequent
you know frequent destructive eating
behaviors those things would give you a
high score
on the low energy availability risk
and i'm just showing you here that the
histogram for that variable the history
of an eating disorder
i think this variable is kind of
interesting and actually an important
part of the story here
so this is a binary variable we asked uh
women if they've ever had an eating
disorder diagnosed you got a one
if you did in a zero if you didn't and i
thought what's interesting here
is actually the the rate of eating
disorders uh or at least a history of
eating disorders was actually pretty
high it was about 30
of the sample so that struck me as kind
of high
now to be fair it was kind of a broad
group of eating disorders it included
some clinical eating disorders like
disordered eating so you may have seen a
high rate just because it was kind of a
broad
definition of eating disorder but it
also does make me worry a little bit
that we're going to have to worry about
selection bias in this data set right
the people who filled out this
questionnaire might have
been you know people who had these
issues might have been more likely
to fill up the questionnaire because
they were interested in these issues so
that's something we're going to talk in
the back of our minds
all right the main dependent variable
here
is this depression score this is the
promise depression score and i'm showing
you the histogram here
it ranges from a score of 8 to a score
of 40 higher scores being more
depression we have pretty wide range of
depression scores in this data set
we also measured the promise anxiety
scores those range from 7 to 35 again we
have a pretty wide range in the data set
besides drawing a lot of histograms
another thing that i'm going to do is to
run some quick
correlation matrices in my data all this
does
is give me a quick sense of which
variables go together these are not
correlation coefficients that i'm going
to report in the paper i'm not i don't
care about the p values
this is just to give me a really quick
sense of which vari which variables are
related with one another
and by the way the correlation
coefficients that i'm showing you here
are pearson correlation coefficients um
and you might wonder like
uh you know but some of these variables
are not normally distributed
uh in fact if i calculated the sphere
and correlation coefficients here i'm
going to get basically the same thing
because we have a pretty big data set we
have over 400 people so it actually
doesn't really matter which
type i um calculate and again i'm not
going to be reporting these
this is just to give us a sense of what
goes together so
for the first thing that pops out when i
did a correlation matrix for depression
and anxiety
is that depression and anxiety are
correlated with one another now that's
not
too surprising but it's important for me
to recognize
because whatever story i see for
depression it's likely i'm going to see
a similar story
for anxiety and actually for just sake
of time for the rest of
today's talk i'm really going to focus
just on the depression score
another interesting thing that jumped
out is that
of all the triad risk factors the one
that really jumped out as being the most
correlated
with depression and anxiety was this low
energy availability risk score
so i actually think this is going to be
an important part of this story here
overall triad risk score was also
moderately modestly correlated but a
little bit less so than that low energy
availability
another thing that popped out that i
thought was interesting is this eating
disorder if you ever had an eating
disorder variable
popped up as having some correlation
with depression and anxiety
and this is actually not surprising
because we actually know
from previous research that eating
disorders tend to co-occur
with depression and anxiety but i think
again this is going to be an important
part of
the story of our data so it's important
to recognize
another thing that jumped out is that
there is a slight inverse correlation
between depression and anxiety and age
the correlations are negative
older women had slightly less depression
and anxiety that's just going to be
important to put in the back of our
minds to remind us that we're going to
need to
adjust for age
all right the last thing that i want to
note on this promise depression
score is that the promised depression
score
can be broken down into categories the
people who put out this
uh this tool have a set of ways of
breaking this up into categories that's
also been validated
and so um you can break it up into none
mild moderate and severe depression
based on their underlying
score and so for this analysis we
actually decided off priority
that we were going to look at the
depression groups rather than the
underlying score
because it had a little bit more
clinical relevance to look at the
depression
groups
what i'm showing you next are some
descriptive statistics for those
depression groups and so uh
here are the sample sizes of those four
groups and what's interesting to note
is that we had a lot of people with mild
or moderate depression but that severe
depression group was actually pretty
small i also calculated the average
triad risk score for each of these
groups
for um no depression and mild depression
it was 2.4 so it actually didn't go up
in the mild depression group
but it did go up to 3.4 in the moderate
depression group and up to 4.9 in the
severe
depression and then the other thing that
i found
interesting again this eating disorder
variable keeps popping up
so if you look at how many people had a
history of eating disorders across these
depression groups it has this nice
russian where it starts at 23 and no
depression group goes up to 30
then 41 and then a whopping 69 in the
severe depression group so again i think
the eating disorders are part of the
story here
all right so that brings us now to our
third step when we're actually going to
be
testing the main hypotheses of this
study
so what kinds of things are we going to
be doing in this step so first of all
we're going to follow our analytic plan
you want to have some analytic plan
before you start
you want to test assumptions of the
model and you want to do a lot of that
testing just by
visualizing the relationships that
you're trying to test
and i think one of the common errors
that i see
when i'm reviewing papers is often
authors will present
models and i'm pretty sure that they
never visualize the relationships behind
those models
and that's a really big problem because
you're not fully testing the assumptions
of the models unless you've actually
looked at the data visually
graphically and also sometimes you're
picking up on artifacts
if you haven't looked at the data
visually you may not realize that
so we're going to build final models and
we're going to interpret the results
for this particular example as i
mentioned
we decided we were going to look at the
depression groups this
non-mild moderate and severe depression
rather than an underlying continuous
score
so that meant that to test the
association between
triad risk scores and depression group
we had to use either ordinal
or multinomial logistic regression we
couldn't use
binary logistic regression here because
our groups have more than two groups we
have four
groups i'm going to show you just the
results today from the multinomial
logistic regression just for time's sake
um i'll tell you that i got a slightly
better fit with the multinomial
regression than with the ordinal
progression and i've adjusted these
models for age because of course that's
a potential confounder here
the other thing we wanted to do was to
explore our data to see if any one
of those components of the triad risk
score seem to be more important than the
others
so now i'm just reminding you here's
what the promised depression groups look
like and i've color coded them today so
here's none and then for the mild group
that i've color coded in moderate is
colored in yellow
and severe is colored in green and i'm
going to stick with that color theme
for the rest of today
so one of the first things i wanted to
do was just to think about
how do i visualize the relationship
between these depression groups
and the triad risk score and i wanted to
come up with something intuitive to
start
so i'm showing you that graphic now so
what you're looking at
is remember the triad risk score is an
integer score
it's 0 1 2 3 all the way up to 10. there
were only two people
who had scores of 9 and 10 though so i
grouped eight nine and ten together
because i wanted enough people to be
able to calculate the percent
uh with each of these types of
depression uh so for example if i look
at everybody who has a triad risk score
of zero that's this group down here
what i've got on the y-axis is this is
the percent with each type of depression
so for example if you had
a triad risk or zero about 28
of that group had mild depression an
additional about 10 percent
the yellow bar here had moderate
depression and then the green bar here
that's just the sliver
about one percent had severe depression
and so this makes kind of intuitive
visualization of the relationship
and you can see there is a trend here
where uh it does seem that the
depression goes up
as you go you increase in the triad risk
score
and in particular you'll notice that a
lot more green at those high triad risk
scores so
it seems like the severe depression
really goes up
and to make this a little bit easier to
see i'm now going to separate out for
you on the right hand side here
mild moderate and severe depression so
if i just look at
the percent with mild depression at each
one of these triad risk scores
what you'll notice is actually it's
pretty flat mild depression does not
increase with increasing triangulus
but if you look at moderate depression
moderate depression
does seem to go up although it plateaus
a little bit after about a score of five
and then finally if you look at severe
depression there really does seem to be
a pretty steep increase in severe
depression as you get to those higher
triad risk scores
so i think this particular graphic is a
nice intuitive
visualization of the relationship um
the graph that i'm going to show you on
the next slide is very much related to
this graph but it's just slightly
more complicated so the graph i'm going
to show you next i'm going to graph not
the percent with depression against
triad risk work
but i'm going to graph something called
the legit of depression
uh against triad risk for just keep in
mind that the logic is just a
mathematical transformation of the
percentage
and so if the percent is higher the
legit will also be higher so you'll see
that it's the same general pattern
um the reason that i'm bothering to do
this more complicated graph with the
legit
is that because logics have nicer
mathematical properties than percentages
so we take the percentage and we do this
mathematical transformation
we come up with the legit which has
these nicer mathematical properties so
for example
a percentage has to range from zero to
one a legit can range from negative
infinity to positive infinity
but i want you to just what i'm showing
you here is a scatter plot of our
observed data and plotting again this
transformation of the percentage against
the triad risk for the pattern though is
exactly the same as i showed you on the
last
graph so these dots represent the
observed data
and then what i've done is i've
superimposed what's called a low as line
or
smoothing line on the data and this is
just to give me a sense of the pattern
of the relationship
ultimately we're going to be fitting
straight lines as i'm going to show you
so we want to make sure that a straight
line fit is a reasonable fit to these
indeed looks like straight lines would
be reasonable if you look just like at
the mile the purple line here you'll
notice that just as before it's pretty
flat
no increase the triangular score the
moderate depression goes up
moderately and the severe depression
goes up more steeply
so what i then did is i fit a
multinomial logistic regression
to these data all that means is that i
fit three lines
and so here's the fitted model on the
right here
it's just i fit three straight lines to
these data
you can notice that the fitted model
looks pretty close
to the observed model so it's a pretty
good we're able to get a pretty good fit
on the data
and what you see here is that um the
purple line that's the mild depression
is basically pretty flat so no increase
in mild depression for the increasing
triad risk
the the slope of the yellow line the
moderate depression line is is
kind of moderate and so there's some
increase in
moderate depression as you go up in
triad risk or and then the slope for the
green line is much steeper so
big increase in severe depression as you
go up in triad risk for
when we go to report those results for
our readers it turns out that most
people can't think in
loges it's not uh it's not an intuitive
unit
and so these slopes the slopes of these
lines are informative but they're in
legit units which nobody can understand
so there's two ways we typically present
the data from logistic regression
so one thing we can do is we can take
the logit and we can transform it back
to a percentage
or what we call a probability a
predicted probability so i'll show you
that in a minute
the other thing is that these slopes
actually have a direct translation of
odds ratios so we can also present
odds ratios
so what i'm showing you now is uh this
is the same graph i showed you before on
the left
this is just the observed percentages or
observed probabilities that i showed you
before
what we can get out of the logistic
regression model one of the things the
model gives us
is predicted percentages or predicted
probabilities
and so that's what you're looking at
here on the right and of course you'll
notice that it's much smoother it has
this nice smooth pattern well that's
because we fit a model to the data so
everything is going to follow a nice
pattern
but you can see it's kind of a
reasonable pattern for
giving the observed data and you can go
in and you can look at well what would
the
predicted percentage with you know
severe depression
be for people with a triad risk war of
zero or for people with a triad risk or
one so you can report that in your view
you can also report odds ratios logistic
regression gives you odds ratios
and i think a lot of people are familiar
with odds ratio so i think this is a
useful
translation of the model um so what
you're looking at here
is the multinomial regression is going
to give you odds ratios for the three
different
groups the three different outcomes mild
moderate and severe depression
these odds ratios the reference group is
no depression
and the units are one point of triad
risk score so i'm showing you here for
example for mild depression
the odds ratio is basically one remember
that for odds ratios an odd ratio of one
means no association we already saw that
right the triad risk score doesn't
appear associated
with mild depression in contrast for
moderate depression we do get a
significantly elevated odds ratio
so how would you interpret this 1.29
so what this means is and this is
adjusted for age is that
for every one point higher triad risk
score every point you go up
that's associated with a 29 increase in
the odds of having
moderate depression relative to no
depression
and then for severe depression of course
you can see the odds ratio is even
bigger
the other thing i wanted to tease out
was i wanted to look not just at the
overall
triad risk score but i wanted to look at
those individual components of the triad
risk for and see if any one of them
dominated so what i did next was
i refit my logistic regression model but
rather than using the overall triad risk
work
i entered those five separate components
uh that each range from zero to two so
the low energy availability
menstrual irregularities for low bmi
score late monarchy and bone stress
injury scores
and these are each going to be adjusted
for each other because of course they're
correlated and i wanted to see it just
if any one of them sort of jumped out
as dominating and so what i'm showing
you now
these are the odds ratios from the
regression model
for severe depression so on the x-axis
these are odds ratios
this vertical line that you see here
that's an odds ratio of one meaning no
association
and what really jumps out here
is there's a strong signal signal for
this low energy availability score
of course the odds ratio is close to
five but of course the the confidence
intervals are really wide because
remember we don't have that many people
with severe depression
so we see a strong signal for low energy
availability and then some signal
for menstrual irregularity and low bmi
but really it's that low energy
availability that seems to jump out
if you look at the odds ratios for
moderate depression really
after adjusting each of these for each
other it's really the low energy
availability risk for that jumps out
as having an elevated association with
moderate depression
and once you adjust for that the other
ones don't seem uh
terribly related to moderate depression
uh and so actually i think this makes
sense and i think what we're seeing
what's going on here in these data is
remember that low energy availability
risk score is based on
eating disorders and abnormal eating
behavior which of course have a
psychological component to them so i
think what we might be picking up on
is that uh for some women part of the
female athlete triad can be
can involve eating disorders and
abnormal eating behaviors
and we know that those things co-occur
with depression and anxiety so i think
that's kind of what we're picking up
here
i'll just show you the odds ratios for
mild depression they're all about one
that's because we didn't see any signal
with mild depression
all right so the fourth step what we're
going to do next is we're going to check
for robustness and what do i mean by
this i mean that we're going to try to
break our analysis we're going to
deliberately try to break our analysis
um we want to make sure that our
analysis doesn't find something just
based on some quirk
uh we want to make sure it's robust so
we're going to try making you know
slight changes to our analysis and
making sure that it doesn't just all
fall to dust if it does then it's not
for us
so one thing you might be wondering
about in this particular analysis
is you might have noticed that i took
that nice continuous depression score
and i tucked it into categories and you
might have even been scolded by a
statistician in the past for doing that
right with that decisions
so no you preserve everything that's
continuous you don't want to lose
information
so you might worry that um what we're
picking up on is some artifact of that
categorization
so one thing i'm going to check i'm
going to go and just make sure that if i
preserve
depression score is continuous that i
still see a signal
so what i did is i took that continuous
depression score
and i ran a linear regression the
depression score is my outcome and the
triad risk for an age is my predictor
and i just wanted to see if i got a
signal
and i do still get a signal the beta
coefficient is 0.94 that's the slope
and all that means is that every one
point higher try on this form
was associated with about a one point
higher depression so i am still seeing a
signal
another uh thing that the the pi
especially was really worried about
with this particular study is that the
questionnaire was administered during
kobit
and we all know that during the
lockdowns on covid people were isolated
and that had an effect on mental health
so she was concerned that we might end
up being just picking up
on you know some artifact of the
pandemic so when she designed the
questionnaire she actually
asked the participants to
retrospectively
answer questions about depression prior
to covet
so we not only had current depression
groups we also had
pre-coveted depression groups so i went
ahead and reran my model on those
feet covenant depression groups just to
make sure that i'm still getting a
similar result and i'm showing you the
odds ratios here
these are similar to the odds ratios i
got with current suppression so this is
not just some
artifact of the pandemic
there's other things we're going to need
to worry about with this data set so one
of the things i might really worry about
uh you know of course these data are all
self-report we didn't
have people diagnosed by a physician the
depression and the female athlete
these are not diagnosed by a physician
there's a self-report so there's some
room for error there
um and then another thing i'm really
going to worry about with these data set
is as i showed you
uh we had a pretty high prevalence of
eating disorders and we also had a
pretty high prevalence of depression
and this does make me worry about
selection bias right people with these
issues may have been more likely to fill
out the questionnaire because they were
interested in these issues
so we're going to have to worry about
that when we're interpreting the data
and we're writing up the paper we're
going to have to
interpret that in context realizing that
there may have been some selection bias
all right so the final thing we're going
to do after we've finished all the other
steps
is we have to get everything ready for
publication
and one of the main things that we're
going to have to do here is we have to
come up with a nice clear clean set of
tables and figures that
tell the story of our data and this is a
bit of a communication task
as well as a coding test the other thing
and of course you have to get those
tables and figures all formatted
correctly for the journal as well that
can take time
the other thing i'm going to be doing is
i'm going to be taking my code which i
must admit
sometimes that i'm doing could you know
sort of for myself it gets a little
messy
i write little notes to myself that only
i can understand so i'm going to have to
go back and clean up my code
to make it readable for other people
so i'm going to take my code which again
might be a little messy when i'm just
doing it quickly
and i'm going to go back and try to make
reproducible code which means i am going
to add a lot of
annotations that other people could
understand
and i am going to make sure that i give
enough code
that somebody could reproduce all the
statistics and graphics
in the paper you know this task of going
back and cleaning everything up can be a
little tedious
but it's actually super useful because
when you have to go back
over your code sometimes you catch
errors in that step and so it's really
good to have to go back and tie
everything up and make it neat
you also need to think about how am i
going to put my data into tables and
figures that communicates a clear
story i like this particular
figure that i showed you earlier because
i think it tells a pretty clear story
so i might actually decide to use this
in the the final paper
um however if you notice uh when i
prepared this figure i did it for this
talk today and so i used kind of funky
colors
i'm probably not gonna keep green and
purple in my uh figure for the journal
um so i'm gonna be cleaning this up a
bit
like improving the color scheme maybe
i'm going to make it
shades of blue or shades of gray um
when i'm making graphs for myself i
often don't bother to make them in high
resolution
for the journal i'm going to have to
render everything in high resolution
i'm going to clean things up like the
labels and i'm going to increase the
font size so when you shrink everything
down it's readable
so this can take a fair amount of time
to tidy up your graphics and make them
uh
good for publication i'm going to point
out one tool that i have found really
useful over the years
in case you haven't come across this
tool before in preparing those final
figures for publication there's a tool
called
the peace tool pacp it's put out by plos
but actually it's useful for submission
to any journal and it allows you to
upload your figures
and it checks those figures to see if
they meet journal requirements and even
though it's the journal requirements of
plots they're kind of the same
throughout
um it's just going to check do you have
the right resolution if you have the
right file type you have the right size
and if you don't meet some of those
requirements it can sometimes even fix
them for you so i found this tool to be
super useful when you get ready for
submissions with journal
all right just to recap here and then
i'll leave a little time for a q a
um our steps of data analysis we're
going to spend a lot of time
processing and cleaning our data and
really getting to understand the
variables in our data set
that's going to help us do a better job
in testing the main hypotheses
and in that step we're going to spend a
lot of time visualizing relationships
then we're going to make sure to check
for robustness make sure the whole thing
is not just continued on some tiny
analytic decision
and then we're going to get everything
ready for publication
before we get to q a here i'm just going
to point out a few other resources
so i have written a statistics column
for a journal for many years
after the journal pm r um you can find a
lot of topics there
uh your statistical topics there i try
to write it in a clear and easy to
understand
way um and in fact if i've made you
curious about multinomial logistic
regression which i talked about today i
happen to have just
written a column on that and i'm posting
the link here but if you
google my name and multinomial logistic
regression it will come up so you can
learn more about
that and then i also teach the medical
statistics certificate program for
stanford online
and if you are planning to analyze your
own data
this is a really good place to start
because i'm going to teach you some
basic coding
and also teach you how to look at and
think about data and how to approach
a data analysis all right i'm going to
now pass this back to jackie for
q a we have a lot of questions that have
been submitted today so we'll get to as
many as possible um thank you all for
submitting your questions
um one of the questions that we've
received is is how
um how folks how learners can get more
content from you so we just covered that
so you can enroll in one of kristin's
courses
to get more content from kristin another
question that has come
up a lot um is folks are interested
in what uh program you recommend
um it sounds like you are typically use
um
sas and they are interested in knowing
if that is the program that you
recommend you recommend python r
or sas and why yeah that's a great
question
i do a lot of my programming in sas i
have to say that's a little bit of an
artifact of my generation
that is i learn sas first and so um
i literally can dream in sas code i do
sas so often and i'm very very fast and
sass
i picked up r afterwards so i am not as
fast in r
so i tend to default to sas particularly
for data processing
um but i often have to go back and forth
between the two because
some of the newest statistical methods
and some of the better graphics are
actually implemented in r
so um i think there are there are
advantages and disadvantages of both sas
is still heavily used
in public health so if you're going to
be in public health you may have some
reason to pick sas
um r is free totally free and the newer
things tend to show up in our
so um i'm happy to advise you on your
individual situation if you want to
email me
um if you can learn a little of both
it's like knowing multiple languages
it's great
um but you know my preference for test
really is just an artifact of when
i would you know when i studied and
south was more dominant then so that's
i'll admit that that's more my reason
for using stuff as opposed to any
logical reason great thank you
um the next question is is there a way
to account for binary variables that may
not be diagnosed for example a diagnosed
history of eating disorders
versus a history of eating disorders
that may not have been diagnosed
yeah so i didn't mention just as a lack
of time that um
we well okay so the question that was
asked in this particular day said they
were asked about both full-blown
clinical you know diagnoses like
anorexia as well as disordered eating
um and then they were asked this whole
series of questions that was actually
trying to get it that if you were not
diagnosed with an eating disorder
but you were frequently restricting your
food that could indicate maybe an
undiagnosed eating disorder or the
subclinical eating disorder so we were
definitely trying to get at that and
that's really reflected in that low
energy availability of this form
right and the next question is if you
are adding
age as a co-variant after seeing the
correlation coefficients does that
not constitute a form of parking
ah okay so that's a great question so i
am
not adding age it would be p hacking or
harking or whatever you want to call it
if i add an h to the model and then i
saw oh my p
value for the thing i care about the
triad risk score and the depression
score my p value got better
when i added age to the model so i am
adding age
based on my knowledge that age is a
potential confounder and i'm not
adding age or putting aging or taking it
out based on how it affects the mean
relationship that i care about
we're really worried about p hacking
with regards to that mean hypothesis am
i doing things
you know fishing around to find a way to
get a significant result in that mean
thing i care about whether age is
significant or not i don't really care i
i'm only including it as
okay great um the next question is um
wondering if you could can differentiate
between
hypothesis testing in descriptive
studies means comparison correlational
studies
with explanatory studies where there is
a need to have
theory to explain the relation in other
words is there any need to have
theory to support comparison studies
that's a great question so one thing
that often gets conflated in statistics
is explanatory
uh modeling where we're testing specific
hypotheses and we have some reason to do
so
versus exploratory data analyses where
we're just
you know describing the data so um those
are two separate
goals when you're for example building a
regression model you might build a
regression model in both
but the goals are totally separate and
so the entire approach is different
what i showed you today was explanatory
modeling we wanted to test a particular
hypothesis
because we had reason to believe that
that association might exist
and all the analysis was focused on that
association
it's totally valuable to sometimes do
exploratory data analysis as long as you
label it as such and are very clear
that's what you're doing because you
might just want to you know look at what
associations are out there without any
preconceived notions just make sure to
label it that way
the next question is can logic
transformation be applied to the
probabilities
in general to get nice data or only when
we use
logistic regression in our analysis
yeah i mean that legit transformation is
a typical transformation
that's used in logistic regression um
and so
again it has some nice mathematical
properties it tends to get used in that
context it may have
you know mathematical transformations
can have many uses um so that's the
common one where you're going to see it
but doesn't mean it could be used
elsewhere
okay and then why did you choose
multinomial regression and not binomial
or
any other regression uh great uh
question yeah so because we had four
levels of that
that depression score i do want to
collapse it into like depression no
depression
because why not use all of that
information but the none mild moderate
and severe so we were either going to
use ordinal
or multinomial both could be appropriate
for these data
it turned out that remember that mild
depression doesn't really increase
with triad risk orb so for that reason
the multinomial
fit turned out a little bit better than
the ordinal um and again i'll refer you
to my recent article on multinomial
logistic regression if you want more
details of that model
great i think we have time for just a
couple more questions so
um the next question is in dividing into
depression groups are the ranges
predetermined
or do you have to decide on the binge
rages by yourself and a follow-up to
that was
if you have to decide on the binge bin
range yourself how would you determine
the appropriate
number of fins and their range that is a
great question yeah so the promised
depression sport it comes with
predetermined bins
that have been validated prior so i am
not doing
i'm not thinking about those ranges
those come with the promised
questionnaire
fortunately because you want those to be
validated you don't want them to be
arbitrary
there are some cases where you might
decide that there's a reason you want to
take a continuous variable and divide it
up into categories
then you want to have you don't want to
like divide it up to count it
you know like we don't want to look at
your data and then decide what
categories you're going to use like
based on the p-value that's the form of
the hacking
you want to have some off-priority
reason that's when you write your
analytic plan of how you're going to
divide up into categories
and so there's some thought that has to
go in that if it's not something that's
already validated in this case it was a
validated
set of categories okay
and the next question is can likert
scale data be
analyzed using parametric tests if they
appear normally distributed
sure so um this in this case we turned a
bunch of likert scales into
more of a continuous score right because
we took eight of them and we put them
together so we ended up with a bigger
uh more continuous score but if you just
had like if let's say we'd only asked
one depression question and you had one
likert scale that was scored say one to
five there it sometimes you're going to
treat those as ordinal
and sometimes you're going to treat
those as continuous and if you have a
big sample size
and it looks kind of even if it doesn't
look normally distributed with a big
enough sample size it's actually okay to
treat that as continuous values but
you'll see statisticians debate this
back and forth you know how should we
treat those ordinal data
and depending on your your end goal
and what the data look like and how big
the sample size is you might make
different decisions for different data
great and i think we have time for one
last question here
and that is how can you know whether the
statistical test you use on your data
is the right one and also with working
with biological data where n is small
how can you determine distribution
okay so the first one uh you know how do
i decide on the statistical model it's
usually based on what's the form of the
dependent variable and then also do i
have correlated data so it's a number of
decision points that i'm going to look
at in terms of what are the data what's
the appropriate statistical model but
then i'm of course going to check all
those assumptions in the model like that
plot we were checking
linearity for example so that's um so
there's often
uh for certain types of data there's a
pretty clear
best model choice or a set of models um
for biological data where you have a
small end
yeah how do you i mean you can draw a
histogram but if you have five people
you're not really going to be able to
tell whether that's normally distributed
or not
for really small data sets you might be
uh best off just reporting descriptive
statistics or defaulting to
non-parametric tests
excellent thank you kristin we're
getting close to the end
of our webinar so we'll need to wrap up
again thank you kristen for this
wonderful presentation
if you'd like to learn more from kristin
we encourage you to join our medical
statistics course
you'll have more than 20 hours of
content in each course to learn from
kristin as well as access to videos and
exercises to sharpen your skills
once again thank you for joining us
today and we hope you have a great week
and we hope to see you again
at our next session thank you kristin
thank you
you